The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
AMIT GANDHI: OK, so today's
topic is going to be biogas
digesters.
So our objectives for the
class, or this session,
are going to be to learn
how biogas digesters
work, when and where
they're appropriate,
some important design
considerations when you're
building biogas digesters.
And then we're going to build
a small-scale one in lab.
So you get to play
with some of the stuff.
Oops, I slipped slides.
So these are some pictures
of biogas digesters.
They've been around for a
couple hundred years, or maybe
150 years.
There are lots of different
forms for them, as you can see.
They scale up.
They can be anywhere from large
industrial ones, like that one,
or they can be smaller scale
ones for just a single farmer
or single family.
And what is a biogas
digester is the question
that you may be asking.
So a biogas digester
is something
that takes organic
matter, normally animal,
human, vegetable waste, and
turns it into gas for cooking
and also turns it into
fertilizer for crops.
So it's basically
taking organic matter
and putting it
through a process,
and you get gas and
fertilizer from that.
The process that breaks
down the organic matter
is anaerobic digestion.
So you have bacteria, which
are found in the organic waste.
And when you put them under
anaerobic conditions, which
means that they're
not exposed to oxygen,
they break down all the organic
waste and form methane gas
and carbon dioxide.
And so you basically have
a giant chamber, I guess.
And in this chamber, you
have your waste here,
with your bacteria in it.
And you let it sit for a while.
It takes about
two weeks for them
to start working once
you get them going.
And they break down the organic
matter in here and produce gas.
And you normally have
an inlet and an outlet.
And what happens is, you
put in more organic matter
through the inlet, and it
pushes out some of the slurry
or whatever's left over.
And so you get
fertilizer from this end.
And the entire time you're
producing gas, which
you can extract from there.
So about biogas, the
composition of biogas
is mostly methane
and carbon dioxide.
So you have about 60% methane,
about 40% carbon dioxide.
And then there are trace amounts
of nitrogen, hydrogen, hydrogen
sulfide, and oxygen.
And the amount
of energy you can
extract from biogas
is 20 megajoules per cubic
meter, which is a fair bit.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: How does
that 20 megajoules
compare to, say, diesel or
traditional fossil fuel?
AMIT GANDHI: I'm not
exactly sure right now.
Yeah, I'll get back
to you on that.
I had a chart with how
it compares to, like, how
it could light things.
But I didn't put it
on here because--
yeah.
And so the parts of
the biogas digester
are kind of like
what I drew here
but better, in this picture.
You have a trench where you
put the biogas digester.
You have the biogas
digester bag,
which is what contains
all of the manure
and the slurry and the gas.
Then you have your
inlet and outlet.
And you have a security valve.
And you have a gas
reservoir as well.
So we're going to
talk a little bit now
about why you would
have a biogas digester.
What are the advantages and
what are the disadvantages?
So now that you've learned
a little bit about it,
we can brainstorm some ideas
about why you would use it
or where you would use it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
water and waste,
does that mean you add water to
it, or it's just whatever is--
AMIT GANDHI: You add water
to it to make a slurry.
So you mix manure and water,
and you get the slurry.
And then you put
it into the system.
You guys will be doing
that later today, too.
So I went to a farm and got
some fresh cow manure for you
to work with.
So yeah.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What are the
typical sizes of [INAUDIBLE]??
AMIT GANDHI: If you
want a ballpark size,
I guess would be maybe
like 10 or 15 feet.
Does that seem right?
15-feet-long, maybe
like this size diameter.
Your trench would be kind
of like this corridor
between the two tables.
That's about the
size that you're
looking at for a
family, a household one.
But they can range from
small to large as well.
So if you look at
this, there's actually
a lot of design that went into
the specific biogas digester.
And so we can look at the
individual components of it
and figure out why, and try to
look through the design process
and thought process
that they used
to come up with this design.
Because this is actually
a pretty clever design
for a biogas digester.
So does anyone notice
anything about this diagram
that seems like a cool--
like a good idea for them
to have done?
AUDIENCE: Security valve?
AMIT GANDHI: Yeah, the
security valve is important.
You don't want your
thing blowing up.
AUDIENCE: Reservoir?
AMIT GANDHI: Yeah, reservoir is
also good because, with this--
because storing gas is
also somewhat of a problem.
And if you don't have a
place to store the gas
and access it pretty easily,
then you're not going to have--
yeah.
Can you guys think
about the fence?
I don't know if you
can see it in there,
but there's a fence around
this specific design.
And the problem-- one of
the things with this design
is that the biogas
digester bag for this
is a big plastic
bag that's covered
in tarp that's sewn together.
And so you have this
giant plastic bag
that's sitting outside.
And one of the cool
things about it
is it's really cheap
because you don't
have to build an external
construction for it.
But it's also-- like,
if you have cattle,
which a lot of times you will
have for something like this,
and your Cow steps on this
bag, it's pretty much ruined.
You're ruining your, like,
$300 biogas digester.
So that's why they
put a fence there.
Can you think of
other advantages
to having a bag, other than
just the fact that it's cheaper?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Is it somewhat
mobile, transportable?
AMIT GANDHI: It's not
really transportable but--
AUDIENCE: Like, if you
had to move location
and you bought a new house,
can you take it with you?
AMIT GANDHI: Oh, you
can't really move--
well, I mean, it's
easier to transport
to the site you're
installing to.
So you can make one
of these and, I guess,
transport them to the location.
I haven't actually
seen that done.
I've seen most of them
being installed onsite
from the raw materials.
But it's definitely easier
to get a large plastic bag
than it is to get
all of the bricks you
would need to build a giant
biogas digester and seal it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Since you want to be
able to control the seal on it,
but since you have a bag, the
volume can actually change.
Even though you say that
it doesn't create a vacuum,
is it--
AMIT GANDHI: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: ----[INAUDIBLE]
the volume changing?
AMIT GANDHI: So that's
actually a pretty cool thing
about this design
is your bag can
get bigger and smaller,
depending on how much gas
is being produced.
Because if you have a rigid
structure, kind of like--
OK.
I'm just going to
redraw what I just had.
So you have a box, and it's
say it's made out of bricks.
You somehow manage to
seal it from the inside
so there's no air
loss or gas loss--
which isn't trivial, for one.
But you managed to do that.
And you put biogas in here.
And it's filling up.
And it's producing methane, or
I guess it's producing biogas.
What happens as you produce more
and more gas in this design,
you start getting a pressure
buildup of gas in here.
And if you're outputting it
into, say, a stove here--
if you are putting
it into a stove
there, depending on
what the pressure is
of the biogas in
this chamber, you're
going to get a fluctuation
in your stove temperature--
or your flame front, which is
kind of annoying and tricky
to work with.
So if you have something
that expands, like a bag,
it's better.
You'll have more of
a constant pressure.
There are some
other designs that
also try to regulate the volume
of the chamber for the gas.
There's one called
a floating dome
one, which is actually
what you'll be making.
And what it is, you
have a giant thing here.
You have your container,
which is solid, in this case.
You have your slurry here.
And then you have
a dome like this
that has your pipe coming out.
And what happens is this
can move up and down inside
of your chamber.
And so, as you produce
more methane gas--
or biogas, rather-- as
the pressure builds up,
it pushes up on the dome so
you're creating more of a space
and regulating pressure with
the size of the chamber, which
is a pretty cool design.
And the ones you guys
are going to be making
are kind of similar to this.
But some of the adaptation
that are going to be--
you're going to take the
bottom of a Coke bottle.
It's kind of like that.
And then you're going
to fill it with water.
And you're going to
have one biogas chamber.
You're going to have
your chamber with slurry.
And then you're going to
have a valve coming into here
and coming out of the water
and going up into that chamber.
So this will be able to move,
based on how much gas you
have in there.
Can you guys think of
any other advantages
to having this sort of
design, other than being
able to regulate
a constant amount?
So how would I know
how much biogas
I'm going to have in this
chamber with this design?
I would have to put basically
a pressure valve on here
and read pressure, which is
kind of annoying and expensive.
And it's not it's not really
easy to get a pressure
valve, in a lot of places.
But with a design like
this, if you let it float,
you can measure just the
height of this chamber
because the higher the chamber,
the more volume of biogas
you have.
So it's almost like
an indicator that
tells you how much
you have as well,
which is also pretty cool.
But I've talked a lot about
how biogas digesters work,
in the design sense.
But we haven't really
got into why they're used
or where they would
be applicable.
So let's think about what
are the advantages of biogas
to other alternative
cooking fuels?
We can start by naming
other sources of fuel.
Someone want to throw
out other sources of fuel
that people use?
So you have charcoal.
You have wood.
Anyone seen other
techniques that they use?
AUDIENCE: Natural gas.
AMIT GANDHI: Natural gas.
I've seen, in other
parts of the world,
people actually just
burn manure straight.
I guess you also
have electricity.
AUDIENCE: Wait, biogas
comes from manure though.
AMIT GANDHI: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Does biogas
mix with the fuel
or if manure is the fuel,
how does manure fuel
without any processing?
AMIT GANDHI: In places, they
just take, like, cow dung
and just burn it
as a fuel source.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AMIT GANDHI: Yeah, they
just take it and burn it.
And then you cook
your food over it.
AUDIENCE: Well, then, what
did the wood burning--
or how do they burn it with, or
how do they light it on fire?
AUDIENCE: It gets dried out.
AMIT GANDHI: Yeah, you
let it sit out in the sun.
It dries out.
It forms a briquette.
And you can just
burn this briquette.
And then it releases
energy when you burn it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It gives off
a lot of bad smoke.
AMIT GANDHI: Yeah.
It gives off a lot of
bad smoke, bad smell too.
And the other thing
about burning manure
directly is that it's kind
of taking a product that's
very rich in
resources, like there's
a lot of organic
matter in there that
could be used as fertilizer.
And instead of using these
good properties of that,
you're just combusting it.
So it's a waste of
resources, basically,
to burn manure directly.
What about wood and charcoal?
What are disadvantages of that?
AUDIENCE: Besides where you're
using the D-Lab method of using
agricultural waste
to make charcoal,
it leads to deforestation
[INAUDIBLE]..
AMIT GANDHI: OK.
That's definitely a big concern.
If you look at Haiti, so
much of Haiti is deforested.
And in places where you
don't have access to--
like, in a lot of parts of,
I guess, India and Nepal,
you'll have areas that are
heavily deforested already.
And so they don't have access
to wood and charcoal even.
And charcoal is expensive there.
And in places like that, where
people are farmers or cattle
farmers, a technology like
biogas digesters makes sense.
Any other disadvantages
to wood, maybe?
Have you ever tried--
AUDIENCE: Collection.
AMIT GANDHI: What?
AUDIENCE: Collection,
time involved.
It's hard to keep
it good and dry.
AMIT GANDHI: Just as a
sense, have any of you
been to developing world
places where you've
seen people cook on three--
stone, wood fires, or
anything like that?
What did you notice about
the cooking process?
AUDIENCE: It's
pretty inefficient.
AMIT GANDHI: Do
want to tell people
about how they cooked there?
AUDIENCE: Well, [INAUDIBLE].
It was my aunt's house.
It was-- I mean, it's
just hard to come up--
it's just hard to get the fuel.
So a lot of times
you just don't cook.
And they end up just
not being able to cook.
AMIT GANDHI: OK.
When they did cook,
what was the process
that they used for
cooking with the wood?
Because it varies,
depending on where you are.
There's a lot of different ways
of combusting wood and using it
in the stove.
What did that stove look like?
AUDIENCE: I was a lot younger.
This was maybe six years ago.
So I think it was just
like buying the wood
and putting the
[INAUDIBLE] the wood.
AMIT GANDHI: OK.
You've--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I'm not
sure what you're getting at.
AMIT GANDHI: Like--
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
AMIT GANDHI: Yeah, OK.
Well--
AUDIENCE: It's just, like, hard
to regulate the temperature.
You have to keep feeding wood
to it to keep it burning.
AMIT GANDHI: Yeah.
And one of the biggest
problems with it
is also just the
smoke that it releases
and the fumes from that,
which are both pretty bad.
Wood fires cause a
lot of pollution.
And most people cook with wood
fires inside their houses.
And indoor air pollution
is a really big problem
throughout the developing world.
And so biogas has the advantage,
where it doesn't release
any of these toxic fumes.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do people complain
about taste with the biogas?
I'm not saying that, like--
but I know several Colombian
people cook a lot on wood
just for the taste.
They say it tastes better.
So is that a drawback?
That maybe it doesn't give
the same taste as wood,
as an open fire.
AUDIENCE: Or is it even fire?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, right,
[INAUDIBLE] or it
could be bad [INAUDIBLE].
AMIT GANDHI: I
haven't seen-- have
you seen that under concern?
I think the way a lot of
people I've seen use--
how are you talking about
them using the wood?
Are you talking about
them barbecuing something
or grilling?
AUDIENCE: No, so what
I remember, it was just
bringing the wood and
then those giant pots--
what are they called?
And they cook, like, a soup
in there, or a chicken.
And even then, it's--
oh, it's wood-fire cooking.
It's currently, you know, how my
mom used to make it, basically.
AMIT GANDHI: Yeah, I don't
have much experience with that.
So, sorry, I can't help.
Do you?
AUDIENCE: I think it
is a behavioral change.
AUDIENCE: I think
a lot of it has
to do with what techniques
do I bring with [INAUDIBLE]..
Because with biogas, you
have to have gas stoves.
You have to have
that sort of thing.
So I know that that's some
problem that they have.
[INAUDIBLE] differently.
AMIT GANDHI: OK.
What about natural gas?
What are some of the problems
associated with natural gas?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: It's expensive
and it's nonsustainable.
Unless It's produced
literally in your area,
you have basically [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: You also need
the lines to connect to you
if you're going to have--
AUDIENCE: So can it
be kind of dangerous?
AMIT GANDHI: I don't know.
I don't think of it as
particularly dangerous.
It just-- you need a
lot of infrastructure
to be able to provide
natural gas to people.
And some places it's
available and not too bad.
When I was working in a favela
in Brazil over this IAP,
they had a truck come
in with natural gas--
or LPG.
And they would bring it
every couple of days,
and at the same time, and
pick up old containers
and give people new containers
for a certain price.
And that seemed
like it was great.
But you can't really have that
same sort of infrastructure
in a more rural
place, for example.
Manure, we already talked about.
And people don't really
cook with electricity
that much in the developing
world, that I've seen.
So yeah, biogas has
a lot of advantages
to these other cooking methods.
But it also requires
certain things.
You basically need a
lot of manure or waste
to go into this biogas
digester every day.
I think the minimum
recommendations
are having maybe two cows
or something like that,
or a few pigs.
And if you don't meet
these conditions,
you're not going to be able
to have a biogas digester that
produces that much fuel
for you to cook off of.
And the investment
for building one
isn't paid back over a
reasonable period of time.
The other thing that's
cool about biogas
is that when you pass your--
I think if you're not
using human waste,
if you're using
manure, and you're
using agricultural waste
or inorganic waste,
if you pass it through
the biogas digester
at the end of it, you
get fertilizer, which
is really good because you're
taking a waste product right
now, which is animal
waste, and it smells bad,
and people try to dispose of
it in ways where they're not
utilizing any value from it.
And you're getting
value from this product,
which is trash right now,
which is a really cool idea.
Plus, when you pass the waste
through the biogas digester,
a lot of the harmful
bacteria get killed off
in the process of producing.
Or like, when it goes
into anaerobic conditions,
a lot of the harmful
bacteria get killed off.
So what you're left
with is good fertilizer
that you can use
to grow crops with.
And, yeah, so it's really
just taking a waste product
and getting value from there.
What are some of
the problems you
can see with biogas
digesters, based off
of this cursory
introduction to them?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You have
to [INAUDIBLE]..
AMIT GANDHI: Yeah.
Well, I guess they
just cost about--
I think the cheapest ones I've
seen are around $300 to build.
But they're on the order
of hundreds of dollars.
And so that's pretty expensive
to shell out at once,
to build one of these.
Another big thing, again--
were you going to say something?
AUDIENCE: Oh, no, I was
going to say maintaining it
and having to put
[INAUDIBLE] fertilizer.
AMIT GANDHI: Yeah.
The maintenance costs
are pretty big as well.
And the problem with this is
there's so many parts, as well,
that are very critical to
the functionality of it,
that if one of them
breaks, you have to fix it.
Otherwise, your
entire thing stops.
Like, if your bag gets a
hole in it, all of your gas
is going to leak out.
So you have to carefully
design it and make it so that--
and you have to really
take care of this.
Because if you don't, then it's
just not going to work anymore.
There are some common sources
of problems that biogas
digesters have over time.
And those are just leaks,
temperature, and pH.
So last year, we did
this lab in D-Lab Energy,
as well, where we
made biogas digesters.
And none of them produced
any methane gas or biogas.
And it was because last
year, unlike this year,
D-Lab was very, very cold.
It was-- like, you needed
to wear jackets around,
or you just wouldn't be
able to walk around here.
And biogas digesters
need a warm temperature.
I think around 50
degrees Celsius,
though that seems high now.
No, that seems high.
I'll get back to you
on the temperature.
But they have a pretty high
operational temperature.
And if they're in that
range, then they work well.
And if they're not in that
range, they don't work well.
So if you're in an area
that gets cold a lot
or has huge temperature
shifts, then your bacteria
that are producing methane
under anaerobic conditions
are going to die out
because of the cold.
And you might have
to come up with some
of heating device for
your biogas digester,
to keep it warm.
The last thing is pH.
For these bacteria
to survive, you
need to have a pH
that's around 7.
So I think 6 to 8 is reasonable.
And if your pH drops below
that or gets raised above that,
then you also have problems
with biogas digesters working.
So yeah, I guess
that's pretty much
all I had prepared
for the biogas,
just like for the
lecture-y part of this.
So do you have any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Are the
bacteria introduced,
or are they [INAUDIBLE]?
AMIT GANDHI: No,
they are found--
I mean, the bacteria that
are in the biogas digesters
are the same bacteria that are
going to be in your stomach
or cow stomachs.
Yeah, so they're
just introduced.
Or not introduced, they're
just found in the manure.
AUDIENCE: So for the
slurry that comes out,
can that be used
directly as fertilizer,
or does it have to be composted?
Because I know when
you use human waste,
you do have to compost it.
AMIT GANDHI: So it needs
to be separated, at least.
Because there's sort of like the
liquid part and the hard part.
Or there's the liquid part
and the solid matter part.
And a solid matter part
is generally composted,
and the liquid part
is used as fertilizer.
Any other question?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: How do you
even collect cow manure?
Do they actually put a
diaper thing on a cow,
or what do they do?
I don't know, actually,
how that works.
AMIT GANDHI: I think they just
scoop it up afterwards, yeah.
AUDIENCE: That seems
like less easy.
Horses are easier because of
the way that they're kept.
But cows are usually
just kept in a field.
It's obviously
harder to do that.
AMIT GANDHI: I think they're
usually tied up though.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AMIT GANDHI: Sometimes.
AUDIENCE: I'm just curious.
AMIT GANDHI: Yeah, but you
don't put that diaper on a cow,
generally.
AUDIENCE: I don't think so.
AMIT GANDHI: I don't think
I've ever seen that, actually.
But you just collect
it off the ground.
AUDIENCE: Are there a lot of
the controls of the design
of the biodigestive--
the valves-- you mentioned
that the security valve
was really important.
I'm sure there's a valve
right before the stove, right?
Where you can turn it on or off.
AMIT GANDHI: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And so there must be--
that gas reservoir is,
like, the gas [INAUDIBLE]
of what you're not using.
But there's pressure
built up there.
So then, there's a pressure
buildup there, but there's--
I'm not sure what the
functions of the main valve
and the security valve
and the gas reservoir are,
and why, if those
two are in place,
it would be an issue
that the pressure would
expand because it would just
go to the gas reservoir.
And the bag wouldn't need to
be able to expand anymore.
AMIT GANDHI: Yeah, so
that's a good question.
I think there are other
designs of biogas digesters
that don't have all of these
security things, necessarily,
built into them as well.
This is a design that
Victor presented.
I don't if you know Victor.
But he's one of the
D-Lab instructors.
And so this was one of the
designs that he presented.
And so I don't
know the specifics
about the different valves.
But I can find out for you
and get back to you next week.
AUDIENCE: Do you know what
the security valve does?
AMIT GANDHI: Yeah,
it just regulates.
It makes it so that, if there's
too much of a buildup of gas,
that the gas can
escape somewhere.
And you don't just
have pipes shooting off
because of high pressure.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: I guess
I just also don't
know what the main valve is.
But [INAUDIBLE].
AMIT GANDHI: So you have
your security valve here.
So that chamber is
going to get bigger.
OK, so you have your bag here.
Then you have your thing going
out to security valve here.
And then you have
your main valve here.
And so when your
main valve is off,
this is sort of a closed system.
And so no gas can
escape out of this.
Because you have-- this
is filled up to here.
I'm drawing this wrong.
So you'll normally have
your sewage level something
like this.
And all your gas is
contained within this region
of your biogas
digester right now.
And so if this valve
is off, and you
keep producing
more and more gas,
your bag doesn't get
bigger and bigger.
And at some point,
it's just going
to explode because of
the excess methane gas.
And so what the
security valve does
is it'll let out that
excess gas to prevent
your system from breaking.
AUDIENCE: Is that
main valve the one
that the person can
control, like, when
they want to start cooking?
Or is there another valve or
a switch, like that stove?
AMIT GANDHI: Generally,
there's a second switch
at the stove end too.
Right?
AUDIENCE: The security
valve is all passive.
You don't have to
turn it on or off.
AUDIENCE: Right, right, right.
So then, what's
the main valve for?
Why would you turn it off?
AMIT GANDHI: I'm not sure.
Yeah, I'm not sure about
the specific design.
AUDIENCE: If your [INAUDIBLE]
is full, can you turn it off?
Be sure not to fill up your
gas [INAUDIBLE] turn it off
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Or if you
had a fire [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Does the security
valve go into the gas reservoir
or out into the air?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, doesn't the
security just release gas
into the atmosphere?
AMIT GANDHI: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So there's too
much going from one side
to the other.
It's just, [INAUDIBLE].
AMIT GANDHI: But
the other thing is,
you also don't want
to have a fully open--
like, one full closed system.
Because if there's a spark
or something like that,
the entire thing is
just going to blow up.
And you--
AUDIENCE: That would prevent
the reservoir from [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Is the gas
reservoir usually
any [INAUDIBLE]
particular, or is it
just a space where you have
to be kept under pressure.
I guess that's kind of
going with the "is there
a second valve?"
AMIT GANDHI: I've seen lots
of different types of gas
reservoirs.
I think the cheapest
one you can do
is can just take another
second smaller bag and seal it.
And then put an inlet
and an outlet on that.
And then this bag just
fills up and expands as--
like it-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can you compress
biogas and it will still--
do people do it in
developing countries?
Just building on your question,
do people compress it?
And then do you have cylinders
of compressed biogas?
Is it possible to do that?
Or that would be like, as
biogas, then [INAUDIBLE]??
AMIT GANDHI: I'm pretty sure
it is possible to do that,
but it's a pretty
sophisticated process.
And I've never seen it done
in rural, developing world.
I've only seen it done
or heard of it being
done on the industrial scale.
AUDIENCE: I'm pretty sure it's
pretty hard to compress it.
AUDIENCE: Compress it?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because there's so
many different kinds of gas
that they start reacting--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that's
what I envisioned.
AUDIENCE: So it's
a lot [INAUDIBLE]..
AUDIENCE: Is there an advantage
to having the gas reservoir--
I don't if [INAUDIBLE]
supply of gas
closer to where the stove
is with your [INAUDIBLE]
AMIT GANDHI: I'm
trying to think.
I mean, there's probably
the user end of it,
where if you see
the reservoir, it's
easier to know how full it
is, and things like that.
It's also a second part
that needs to be protected,
if you're using
a bag to make it.
And so if you're
leaving it outdoors,
like right next to
your biogas digester,
maybe it's more
likely to get damaged.
And if you're putting this
inside your house or something
like that, or in a
more protected area,
that would make it easier.
But yeah.
So Victor is actually
really experienced
with biogas digesters.
So if we have more questions,
we can have him come in
and talk a little bit
about it if we have time.
And if you guys are
doing a biogas project
for your specific
projects, or related to it,
then you should also
talk to Victor about it,
to get more information.
So I'm trying to give you more
of a general idea of how they
work and what things to
take into consideration when
building one or looking
at an existing design,
more so than a
very in-depth thing
because there are
people in D-Lab who
a lot more about biogas
digesters than I do.
So I guess if there are
no other questions--
before we go down, I'm going
to go through the muddy card
questions from last week's lab.
Most of the questions
were all about the guts
of how a PV panel works
and photovoltaics work.
Yeah, we're going to do a
solar cell lab next week.
And the first half
of that is just
going to be talking to you
about how PV systems work.
So if you guys can wait
another week for that,
then you'll have it
presented to you.
And then, one person asked
about why you shouldn't
spot weld galvanized steel.
And when anything is galvanized,
what you're doing is,
you're coating it with zinc
so that it doesn't rust.
And when you try
to weld anything
with zinc coatings on it, you
vaporize the zinc coating,
and it's pretty toxic to you.
So if you're doing it in a
really well-ventilated area
or you're doing it outdoors,
it's not a big deal.
But if you're doing it
indoors, it's toxic.
So you want to
make sure you avoid
welding galvanized materials.
So now what we're going
to do is we're going
to break up into two groups.
Well, first off, we're going
to be building five biogas
digesters, little modules.
So you should group up into
groups of two or three,
until we got five of them, Well,
actually let's just do two.
Let's do four biogas
digester things today.
So we'll break up into
groups of threes and four.
And then, two of those groups
are going to go with Becca,
and she's going to teach
you about plastic sealing
and how to make biogas digester
slurry from manure and water.
And the other group is
going to go with me,
I'll walk you through
cutting the wood
and putting it together to
build the biogas digester.